ja das hier ist genau das video das ihr
gesucht habt ihr beantworten wir sieben
kritische fragen zu den chor oder info
holt durch ein team macht es sich
gemütlich los geht's frage eins waren
ging das so schnell mit der
impfstoffentwicklung und vor allem kann
es so schnell noch sicher sein es gibt
sechs gute gründe warum es so schnell
geht
erstes haben besonders viele daran
geforscht globale pandemie globaler
fokus in der forschung das erhöht
natürlich die wahrscheinlichkeit auf
erfolg zweitens es gab besonders viel
geld für die entwicklung und zwar
wirklich viele drittens ähnlichkeit zu
saas 1 und mehr es beides ja auch
coronaviren so musste man hier nicht
komplett bei null anfangen hiltons
überlappung von prozessen eine impfstoff
entwicklung folgt einem streng
kontrollierten prozess um die
pharmazeutische qualität die wirksamkeit
und die sicherheit zu gewährleisten
das war hier nicht anders so dieses mal
konnten prozesse parallel ablaufen und
sich teilweise überlappen durch
priorisierung und genügend ressourcen so
ging es natürlich schneller aber es war
nicht weniger sorgfältig rowling reviews
anstatt zu warten bis ein
wissenschaftlicher bericht vollständig
vorliegt prüfen die behörden derzeit
kontinuierlich also sie prüfen
datensätze sofort sobald sie da sind
sechs hohes infektionsgeschehen jetzt
das ist an sich natürlich schlecht aber
für eine klinische impfstudie
tatsächlich gut denn die funktioniert so
die testgruppe kriegt den impfstoff die
kontrollgruppe eine placebo spritze und
dann schaut man die nächsten monate
einfach was so passiert hier sind die
daten von bayer und texter impfstoff die
kurve 19 fälle in der kontrollgruppe
steigen immer weiter
während die geimpften nach kurzer
anlaufzeit kaum mehr krank werden und je
stärker eine pandemie wütet also je
schneller sich leute anstecken desto
schneller sieht man ein unterschied
deswegen konnten klinische studien
innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit mit
eindeutigem ergebnis abgeschlossen
werden
fazit die impfstoffentwicklung war so
schnell weil sie priorisiert wurde und
entsprechende ressourcen rhein gepumpt
wurden plus eine
pandemie die gewährleistung der
pharmazeutischen qualität der
wirksamkeit und der sicherheit wurde
genauso sorgfältig gehandhabt wie bei
anderen impfstoff entwicklungen frage 2
ist der astra zeneca impfstoff gut genug
jetzt wurde ein dritter impfstoff
zugelassen von astrazeneca und zwar in
so genannter vector im stoff mit einer
effektivität von 70 prozent das heißt in
den klinischen studien erkrankten 18 von
1000 nicht geimpften an coop 19 also es
wurden hier nicht nur 1000 leute
getestet sondern insgesamt rund 24.000
man schaut hier pro 1000 probanden um
besser zu vergleichen also 18 von 1000
nicht geimpften wurden krank bei den
geimpften waren es 5 von 1000 das heißt
13 menschen weniger also 70 prozent
weniger
daher kommen also die 70 prozent
effektivitäts die stiko die ständige
impfkommission empfiehlt derzeit in
astrazeneca impfstoff für erwachsene bis
64 jahre für ältere haben die bisherigen
daten noch nicht genug statistische
power um die wirksamkeit sicher zu
beurteilen
es kann aber gut sein dass die
empfehlung demnächst noch erweitert wird
sobald die daten da sind bis dahin kann
es sein dass manche jüngere
gegebenenfalls aus rio zwei oder drei
vorrücken können also früher dran kommen
könnten was diejenigen ja freuen dürfte
außerdem muss der vector impfstoff nicht
so stark gekühlt werden wie die m r
enner impfstoffe was ein logistischer
großer vorteil ist so könnten irgendwann
vielleicht auch die hausärzte impfen
auch super jetzt denken sich manche aber
vielleicht wird aber kein impfstoff
zweiter klasse ja klar wenn ich jetzt
die wahl hätte zwischen einem impfstoff
mit 95% effektivität und einem mit 70
prozent würde ich natürlich auch den
effektiveren nehmen aber dieses szenario
wird sie erst mal nicht geben wir haben
natürlich viel weniger impfdosen als wir
brauchen und es wird auch eine zeit und
auch so bleiben
das heißt man wird auf absehbare zeit
wahrscheinlich nicht frei wählen lassen
sondern die impfdosen sie
vollauf teilen anders gesagt ich muss
das nehmen was ich kriegen kann
und das ist auch völlig okay dann sagen
wir jetzt das krankheitsrisiko meine oma
wäre jetzt hier ja dann ist ja mein
risiko schon mal niedriger und wenn es
meine oma durch die impfung das risiko
um 95 prozent reduzieren kann und ich um
70 von hier aus
dann ist mein risiko am ende auch nicht
mehr viel höher als sie es also das
nimmt sich in der praxis gar nicht mehr
so viel diese 25 prozent unterschied
scheinen größer als sie tatsächlich sind
70% effektivität sind wirklich solide
also wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
em-arena impfstoffe mit ihren 95
effektivität unsere erwartungen weit
übertroffen haben das heißt wir
vergleichen jetzt gerade mit einem sehr
hohen standard außerdem ist diese
impfung vielleicht gar nicht die einzige
die es geben wird vielleicht wird eine
saisonale impfung vielleicht gibt es im
herbst eine zweite im grunde oder
vielleicht muss man sowieso irgendwann
noch mal impfen weil die impfungen sich
an die neuen mutationen anpassen müssen
siehe auch frage 6 frage 3 können gegen
basierte impfstoffe mai nähert gut
verändern um das zu beantworten brauchen
wir erstmal ein paar basics so sieht das
grüner virus ja ungefähr haus also an
seiner oberfläche sitzen so starken
artige proteine die bike proteine
man kann das bike protein alleine als
impfstoff nutzen weil das protein
erleide natürlich nicht gewinnt 19
auslösen kann es aber ausreicht um unser
immunsystem zu aktivieren und für das
echte virus zu trainieren weil wir
damals vom echten krone virus infiziert
werden denkt sich das immunsystem h da
ist kenne ich und der angriff wird
idealerweise im keim erstickt viele
impfungen beruhen darauf dass man nur
teile von viren nimmt oder auch ganze
abgetötete viren der nachteil ist
allerdings die aufwendige herstellung
beispiel influenza impfungen die werden
in der regel in hühnereiern gezüchtet
was ziemlich lange dauert und ziemlich
lange dauern könnte gerade nicht
gebrauchen weil wir schnell impfstoffe
brauchen und das auch noch in rauen
mengen und hier liegt der große vorteil
von gen basierten impfstoffen hier
werden kleine teile der virus dna oder
ehren
in die zelle eingeschleust und zwar nur
der teil er den bauplan für das protein
trägt ist der bauplan erst mal unseren
zellen geht der abgelesenen unsere
zellen produzieren das protein selbst
diese gehen basieren impfstoffe sind im
labor relativ leicht herzustellen und
die eigentlich komplizierte herstellung
des proteins übernehmen wir selbst alle
bisher zugelassenen impfstoffe sind
gehen basiert es gibt die 2 mrd
impfstoffe von moderner & beyond inc
pfizer und es gibt den neuen impfstoff
von astrazeneca einen vektor impfstoff
und dna impfstoff es gibt noch zwei
weitere gehen basierte impfstoffe auf
deren zulassung wir bald hoffen können
nämlich ein mr impfstoff vom tor weg und
ein weg der impfstoff von johnson &
johnson schauen wir uns mal das prinzip
mr impfstoff und vector impfstoff etwas
genauer an
rektor impfstoffe um das corona spike
gehen einzuschleusen nutzt man harmlose
viren als eine art transport mit diese
transportieren nennt man vektoren daher
sektor impfstoff man kann replizierende
vector nehmen also wären die sich
vermehren können aber harmlos sind zum
beispiel abgeschwächte masernviren so
ein konzept hatte auch der ebola dem
stoff oder man nimmt nicht replizierende
vektoren also viren die sich nicht
vermehren können
weil die entsprechenden gene deaktiviert
wurden genau das hat astrazeneca mit
adenoviren gemacht dass krone virus
gehen das den bauplan für spike protein
trägt wird in dem sektor die and a
eingebaut und durch das vector virus in
die zelle und in den zellkern
eingeschleust im zellkern passiert
folgendes das bike gehen also die dna
wird kopiert und in m rna umgeschrieben
mrsa steht für messenger rna also boten
rna sie trägt den bauplan aus dem
zellkern zu den ribosomen den protein
fabriken unserer sell
dort werden die nächste bauanleitung
dann dieses bike proteine hergestellt
und damit die immunantwort gestartet mmr
impfstoff america im stoffe wie der von
beyond inc pfizer nutzen nicht dna
sondern direkt mr
man ist also hier quasi einen schritt
weiter der rest bleibt grundsätzlich
gleich hier braucht man keine vektoren
sondern
nutzt solche lipid hüllen als
transportmittel die dm arena ins
zellplasma einschleusen
die m rna muss nämlich nicht in den
zellkern im zellkern findet die
transkription von dna zu mr innerstadt
doch dieser schritt wird ja hier gespart
aber ist es nicht gefährlich wenn virus
rna oder dna in unsere zellen geschleust
wird kann dadurch unser erbgut verändert
werden fangen wir mit den m rna
impfstoff namen hier gibt es mehrere
gründe warum das nicht passieren kann
erstens die mrn angelangt nur ins ziel
plasma und nicht in den zellkern und dem
zellkern sitzt ihr unsere dna das heißt
die em arena kommt mit unserer dna gar
nicht in kontakt weiteren aka nicht so
ohne weiteres in dna umgeschrieben
werden
der prozess läuft wie gesagt andersrum
drittens das kroner virus bringt ja
selbst seine er in unsere zellen wenn
wir uns damit infizieren und zwar seine
gesamte und nicht nur das es verwehrt
sich ja auch noch in unseren zellen
das heißt wer angst vor viren genen hat
müsste mehr angst vor krone haben als
vor der impfung nur dass diese angst
eben unbegründet ist also natürlich kann
eine krone infektion gefährlich seien
aber nicht weil dabei unsere gene
verändert werden was passiert bei der
infektion nicht um bei der impfung
entspricht auch nicht okay für die
impfstoffe wie der von astrazeneca
gelten all die gründe die ich gerade
genannt habe nicht den hier schleusen
wir nicht er sondern den an die zelle
ein und zwar nicht nur institute plasma
sondern wirklich in den zellkern kann
sich fremde dna in unserem zellkern in
unser genom einbauen grundsätzlich geht
das schon nur ganz so einfach ist es
nicht etwa acht prozent des menschlichen
genoms besteht aus wieren dna ja es gibt
nämlich während die ihr erbgut ins wirtz
genome einschreiben können zb das
retrovirus hiv einfach so geht es aber
nicht sondern nur mit hilfsmitteln und
zwar gibt es ein enzym namens reverse
transkriptase das diesen prozess
umkehren kann also rna in dna umwandelt
und da noch ein zweites enzymen damit
integra
damit dient dna dann tatsächlich auch in
die wird dna integriert also eingebaut
werden kann bei den corona impfungen
sind diese notwendigen enzyme natürlich
nicht aber das ist das erst zweitens die
viren die astrazeneca oder johnson &
johnson als vektoren benutzt sind
adenoviren adenoviren kennen wir auch
von unseren harmlosen erkältungsviren da
sind auch adenoviren mit dabei und
adenoviren zählen zu den nicht
integrierenden viren
sie schleusen sich zwar in den zellkern
1 liegen da aber wieso mal vor das heißt
neben unserer dna
und außerdem führt das ablesen der spike
dna hier zur produktion von den spike
proteinen die er dann von immunsystem
attackiert werden wobei die zellen die
die virus proteine herstellen dann
sowieso getötet werden also die
befürchtung dass gen basierte impfstoffe
durch die nun veränderungen
nebenwirkungen auslösen könnten sind
unbegründet aber schauen uns die sorge
über nebenwirkungen mal etwas
allgemeiner anfrage es hier was ist mit
sehr seltenen aber schweren
nebenwirkungen erst mal kurz zu den
häufigen nebenwirkungen wie leichter
schmerzen an der einstichstelle oder
abgeschlagenheit diese symptome sind
teil der normalen impfreaktion man sagt
auch reaktor genäht und anzeichen dafür
dass unser immunsystem wie gewünscht
seinen job macht schwerere
nebenwirkungen sind bei impfungen selten
denn die sicherheitsansprüche an eine
impfung sind einfach extrem hoch also
bei einem krebsmedikament gegen einen
tödlichen krebs kann man auch schwerere
nebenwirkungen in kauf nehmen bei einer
impfung die gesunden menschen
verabreicht wird nichts aber je seltener
eine nebenwirkung desto schwieriger ist
sie zu entdecken bei beyond inc pfizer
hatte man in phase 3 also in der letzten
klinischen studie vor der zulassung über
40.000 probanden was sehr viel ist
normalerweise sind es eher tausende und
10.000 auch wenn er neben wirkung nur in
einem von 10.000 fällen auftritt würde
man sie auch bei dieser probaten größe
nicht als statistisch signifikant
wahrnehmen
zumal ja auch nur die hälfte der gruppe
geimpft wird die restlichen 20.000 sind
hier in der placebogruppe impfstoffe
werden also mit einem restrisiko für
seltene nebenwirkungen zugelassen
deswegen gibt es bei impfstoffen genau
wie bei medikamenten eine phase 4 also
eine sorgfältige beobachtung nach der
zulassung als infektionsschutzgesetz
schreibt vor dass jede nebenwirkungen
die nach einer impfung auftritt dem
gesundheitsamt gemeldet werden muss das
paul-ehrlich-institut sammelt dann alles
übrigens kann es auch jede und jeder
selbst melden zum beispiel über dieses
formular
die schwierigkeit bei phase 4 ist dass
wir dann keine kontrollgruppe mehr haben
also wir haben natürlich viele nicht
geimpfte aber das bringt ja nichts wir
bräuchten nach wie vor eine gruppe der
wir eine placebo spritze in den armen
gehen
da wird es nicht mehr haben sind
nebenwirkungen vor allem wenn sie so
vereinzelt und selten auftreten gar
nicht so einfach der impfung zu
zuschreiben oder auch nicht es geht bei
phase 4 darum aufmerksam zu sein zu
beobachten und verdachtsfälle ausfindig
zu machen die man im zweifelsfall dann
näher untersucht okay aber warum macht
man da nicht noch eine klinische studie
eine größere mit 100.000 probanden und
mit gescheiter kontrollgruppe
man könnte das machen das würde den
impfstoff aber natürlich noch
zurückhaltend der statistischen risiko
abwägung kommt man einfach irgendwann an
einen punkt wo man ganz klar mehr
schaden anrichtet wenn man einen
impfstoff zurückhält der schon an
zehntausenden getestet sich als sicher
erwiesen hat als wenn man dennoch weiter
testet nur um dass bereits geringe
risiko noch ein stückchen mehr zu
verringern das risiko steht ihr ohnehin
schon in keinem verhältnis zu den
risiken von 519 frage 5 was ist mit
langzeitfolgen und war da nicht was mit
narkolepsie was wenn viel später
nebenwirkungen auftreten die sich in den
ersten tagen wochen monaten nach der
impfung noch nicht zeigen oft wird in
diesem zusammenhang auf die impfung
gegen schweinegrippe verwiesen bei deren
impfstoff namens pandemrix narkolepsie
ausgelöst hat michael epp sie ist eine
relativ seltene krankheit die unter
anderem mit katar plexi einhergeht katar
plexi ist ein plötzliches erschlaffen
die muskeln so dass sich die betroffenen
eine
weil ein nicht bewegen können so ähnlich
wie eine ohnmacht bei vollem bewusstsein
der pandemrix narkolepsie fall ist
unglaublich spannend also wirklich wie
11 krimi und auch noch ziemlich relevant
für die korona impfungen
allerdings ist das ganze sehr komplex
damit dieses video nicht gesprengt wird
hat lars aus unserem meile team quasi
extra für euch einen blog artikel dazu
geschrieben in dem alles im detail
erklärt wird kann ich nur wärmstens
empfehlen denn danach wisst ihr wirklich
ganz genau bescheid yanar collapse sie
eine chronische krankheit ist ist der
pandemrix fall ein seltenes fall
beispiel dafür dass eine impfung
nachhaltige schäden also langzeitschäden
verursacht hat aber die symptome für
narkolepsie die traten meist nach
wenigen wochen bis monate nach der
impfung auf und so ist auch die
erfahrung mit anderen impfungen und
wohlgemerkt laufen die klinischen
studien der mrta impfstoffe schon seit
sommer 2020 und die laufen die immer
noch und zumindest bis jetzt haben sich
noch keine verspätete nebenwirkungen
gezeigt auch hier könnte man natürlich
die studien länger laufen lassen
aber auch hier müsste man dann
verantworten den impfstoff so lange
zurückzuhalten
das risiko dass völlig unerwartet
verspätete nebenwirkungen auftreten die
man bis jetzt nicht auf dem schirm hat
ist so klein dass es in keinem
verhältnis steht zu den risiken von
kurven sinn also auch hier gilt wer
jetzt eine impfung ablehnt und lieber
noch wartet ist risikofreudiger als
jemand der ein impf angebot annimmt
frage 6 helfen die impfungen gegen die
neuen virus mutanten viren vermehren
sich ja indem sie in wirtszellen ganz
viele kopien von sich machen und bei
diesem kopiervorgänge passieren immer
wieder kleine fehlerchen also kleine
mutationen im erbgut des virus die
meisten dieser mutationen haben auch
keine weitere bedeutung aber es kann
immer mal wieder passieren dass rein
zufällig eine mutation dabei ist die
irgendeinen vorteil gegenüber dem
wildtyp also dem original hat also dass
die mutante zum beispiel ansteckender
ist und wenn so ein vorteil besteht kann
sich diese mutante gegenüber dem wildtyp
durchsetzen
evolution mutationen müssen nicht
zwingend schlecht
also evolutionstechnisch ist es für das
virus sogar gut weniger tätig zu werden
dafür aber ansteckend also das beste was
uns passieren kann ist dass es sehr
ansteckend ist aber dass der wirt so fit
ist dass er umläuft und am besten noch
ganz viele andere leute anstellt damit
es sich um so mehr verbreiten kann
momentan haben wir den salat dass wir
mutanten haben die nicht weniger
schädlich sind aber ansteckender tricky
wie jetzt wenn sich die mutation das
protein so stark verändert dass unser
immunsystem ist nicht mehr erkennen kann
dann spricht man von im juni scale also
das virus kann der immunantwort entgehen
aber heißt das dass alles wieder von
vorne losgeht denn wir werden jetzt
keine zweite pandemie also 2020 wird
jetzt nicht wieder von vorne losgehen
denn man kann nicht davon ausgehen dass
sich das virus so krass mutiert dass es
plötzlich ein ganz anderes virus ist mit
dem unser immunsystem gar nichts mehr
anfangen kann
also wer geimpft ist oder auch wer die
krankheit schon mal durchgemacht hat
kann sich dann mit irgendeiner neuen
mutante vielleicht nochmal anstecken
darf dann aber trotzdem mit einem
milderen verlauf recht weil man dann
eine gewisse grund oder kreuzimmunität
hat das kritische ist aber dass wir
jetzt schon bevor die ausreichend
geimpft sind
die ansteckenden mutanten schon im
umlauf waren das heißt dass wir jetzt
noch sehr stark auf unsere anderen
maßnahmen auf unsere schutz und
hygienemaßnahme angewiesen sind und wenn
die nicht richtig greifen dann laufen
wir viel leichter in neue ausbrüche und
wellen und auch londons rein also sowas
kann tatsächlich immer wieder passieren
aber zu impfen effektivität also
zumindest bei der britischen variante b
11 7 die ja bei uns noch am stärksten im
umlauf ist scheint es gut auszusehen da
scheinen bisher alle impfstoffe trotzdem
zu wirken über andere mutanten wie die
südafrikanische variante gibt es derzeit
beunruhigende medienberichte aber noch
wissen wir einfach nicht genau wie es
damit der impfstoff wirksamkeit aussieht
und es ist natürlich nicht
ausgeschlossen dass das geraune wir es
auch noch weiter mutiert so lange bis
die impfungen vielleicht nicht mehr
richtig greifen dann
müssten die impfstoffe tatsächlich
angepasst werden und hier ist dann
wieder der große vorteil der gen
basieren impfstoffe weil die könnte man
deutlich schneller und einfacher
anpassen und neu herstellen als
impfstoffe die erst gezüchtet werden
müssen
frage 7 sollten die impfte mehr
freiheiten bekommen sollten geimpfte
wieder in restaurants auf konzerte oder
in clubs gehen können es ist natürlich
eine rechtliche und gesellschaftliche
frage aber ihr liegt eine wesentliche
wissenschaftliche frage zugrunde nämlich
die frage nach der stabilisierenden
immunität also können geimpfte andere
noch weiter anstecken
bisher wissen wir eigentlich nur von
einer komplett sterilisieren immunität
kann man nicht aus das heißt die impfen
können andere immer noch anstecken aber
eine impfung kann das ansteckungsrisiko
für andere anscheinend reduzieren wir
wissen nur nicht wie viel und so lange
wir das noch nicht wissen also diese
frage muss uns die wissenschaft
beantworten können wir natürlich auch
diese rechtliche und gesellschaftliche
frage gar nicht sinnvoll abwägen dass
hier nur so als kleiner reminder
schreibt gerne in die kommentare was ihr
dazu denkt und falls sie noch eine frage
habt also eine wissenschaftliche frage
zu den impfungen die wir nicht
beantwortet haben könnt ihr sie stellen
unter dem hashtag keks frage
dann werden jetzt lassen sich in den
nächsten tagen immer mal wieder nach
diesen heftig gucken und versuchen so
viele fragen wie möglich zu beantworten
eine frage haben wir extra ausgelassen
nämlich die frage können irgendwo mann
unfruchtbar machen denn diese frage hat
der liebe martin moser so gut
beantwortet dass wir den nichts mehr
hinzuzufügen hatten und stattdessen
verlinken wir einfach auf sein video
zusammen mit einer ganz fetten keks und
viel
also eine arbeitsteilung für den ganzen
kanal wir sehen uns wald und bis dahin
bleibt sicher